as you might expect I have been
researching nonstop about this apparent
powerful AI discovery that inside as a
open AI said could threaten Humanity
I've spoken to every Insider I know and
done a ton of research and I am not
claiming to have solved the puzzle but I
can provide some genuine clues that I
think will be at least part of the
answer normally I like to be a lot
firmer than that but this is the best I
can do now the first thing to note of
course is that open AI have now denied
that samman's ala was precipitated by
this safety letter to the board as my
previous three videos have shown there
was certainly a lot else going on so it
might well not just be about this AI
breakthrough second I just want to
quickly debunk this clip that's doing
the rounds where people are claiming
that Sam Alman called this new creation
a creature not just a tool actually if
you watch to the end he's very much
saying he's glad that people now think
of it as part of the tool box so despite
this frantic headline I am not trying to
overhype things but I genuinely think I
figured a couple of things out let's get
to it later in the article these
insiders these researchers flagged up
work by an AI scientist team the
existence of which multiple sources
confirmed this AI scientist team was
formed by combining earlier Coen and
math gen teams at open aai their work on
exploring how to optimize existing AI
models to improve their reasoning was
flagged in the letter to the board now
there is very little public information
about either the Coen or math gen teams
but I dredged up this old tweet from Sam
wman yes by the way I am now on Twitter
I finally succumbed anyway Sam said
really exciting process supervision
result from our math gen team and he
linked to a critical paper that I
covered back in the spring it's called
let's verify step by step and that paper
is the Crux of the video that's why I
think the former math gen now ai
scientist team were working on and take
this tweet in September by by gnome
Brown at openai my teammates and I at
openai are hiring ml Engineers for
research on llm multi-step reasoning we
recently hit a state-of-the-art 78% on
the math benchmark which I'll get to in
a second our new plans are even more
ambitious I'm only just getting started
but you might already be glimpsing why I
think this paper is the Croc of the new
development here's another reason what's
much more ambitious than 78% acing such
tests that's apparently what they've
achieved behind the scenes at least
according to Reuters and what's another
bit of evidence well we have this
exclusive report from the information
again similar frantic headline open AI
made an AI breakthrough before ultman
firing stoking excitement and concern
but who led that breakthrough the
technical breakthrough they say was
spearheaded by open aai Chief scientist
Ilia satova and the most recent paper on
archive listing Ilia sukova as an author
is the let's verify step-by-step paper
now at this point I know you want me to
get to what it means but with so many
theories floating out there I want to
give you yet more evidence that at least
one of the breakthroughs links to Let's
verify step by step and I think I might
even know what the other breakthrough is
the same article in the information
talks about sover working on ways to
allow language models to solve tasks
that involve reasoning like math or
science problems it talks about how he
had this secret program called gp0 and
here's where it gets interesting the
team hypothesized that giving language
models more time and computing power to
generate responses to questions could
allow them to develop new academic
breakthroughs and Lucas Kaiser who we
will definitely be seeing more of in
this video indeed he appears in the
thumbnail apparently held a key role in
the gp0 project and look at this among
the techniques the team experimented
with was an ml concept known as test
time computation that's apparently meant
to boost language models problemsolving
abilities and we have aund speculations
online about what this might mean but I
knew that name rang a bell and I dug up
this 2021 paper which cites test time
comput and what is this random paper
that Philip is talking about well it's
from open Ai and look at some of the
co-authors KL Cobb of the math gen team
and Lucas Kaiser cited in the
information this was actually one of the
precursor papers to Let's verify step by
step which I will explain in a moment it
introduced the now famous in ml circles
GSM 8K data set that's 8,000 grade
school math problems more importantly
though it Tri this method of at test
time generating many candidate Solutions
and selecting the one ranked highest by
a verifier and I'm going to massively
oversimplify at this point and just say
that a verifier is a separate model
trained only at this point in this paper
to spot good Solutions solutions that
get the answer correct and what the
paper proposed was getting the base llm
to generate hundreds of Solutions and
then getting this separate verifier to
spot the ones that were likely the most
correct and in a nutshell the authors
noticed that if they invested more
computing power in generating more
solutions and taking a majority vote
among the top verifier ranked solutions
that had a massive effect on performance
and that's what it means by test time
compute investing your computing power
while you're taking the test not during
training so the model stays the same
you're not further training it or
fine-tuning it you're investing that
computing power during test time again
to generate potential Solutions and take
majority votes amongst them
self-consistency they found that using a
verifier in this way was better than
fine-tuning because verification was a
simpler task than generation it's easier
to check your answers than generate good
ones so investing time in checking
answers was more fruitful how much more
fruitful well the use of verifiers
results in approximately the same
performance boost as a 30 times model
size increase and then it gets prophetic
when it says and verifiers scale
significantly better with increased data
and to hammer the point home they said a
6 billion parameter model with
verification slightly outperforms a
fine-tuned 175 billion parameter model
again thereby offering a boost
approximately equivalent to a 30X model
size increase and that team by the way
with Lucas Kaiser was probably drawing
on work by a single dude done 6 months
earlier in April 2021 while studying the
board game hex the researcher Andy Jones
found an interesting result he said
along with our main result we further
show that the test time and train time
compute available to an agent can be
traded off as we've seen while
maintaining performance I read that
paper in full and it was cited by no
other than gnome Brown he's the guy we
saw earlier who joined openai in July of
this year he said he's investigating how
to make reasoning methods truly General
if successful we may one day llms that
are a thousand times better than GPT 4
and later in that thread he cites that
same paper from Andy Jones and he
concludes with this all those prior
methods are specific to the games
they're talking about but if we can
discover a general version the benefits
could be huge yes inference may be a,x
slower and more costly but what
inference cost would we pay for a new
cancer drug or for a proof of the famous
mathematical rean hypothesis and we'll
come back to mathematical hypotheses in
a moment anyway improve capab ities are
always risky he went on but if this
research succeeds it could be valuable
for Safety Research as well notice that
point about capabilities being risky it
does seem to me to be linking together
into that reuter story imagine he says
being able to spend $1 million on
inference to see what a more capable
Future model might look like it would
give us a warning that we would
otherwise lack is that what open aai did
when they recently push back the veil of
ignorance did they just spend a million
dollars on inference and and see what a
more capable Future model might look
like so that's test time computes but
what about let's verify step by step
well going back to that original 2021
verifier paper they said this the
problem that they noticed with their
approach back in 2021 was that their
models were rewarding correct Solutions
but sometimes there would be false
positives getting to the correct Final
Answer using flawed reasoning they knew
this was a problem and so they worked on
it and then in May of this year they
came out with let's verify step by step
in this paper by getting a verifier or
reward model to focus on the process the
P instead of the outcome the O results
were far more dramatic next notice how
the graph is continuing to rise if they
just had more let's say test time
compute this could continue Rising
higher and I actually speculated on that
back on June the 1st that difference of
about 10% is more than half of the
difference between gpt3 and GPT 4 and
also is it me or is that line continuing
to grow suggesting that when more
compute is available the difference
could be even more Stark imagine a
future where GPT 4 or 5 can sample say a
trillion 10 to the 12 Solutions so
you're beginning to see my hypothesis
emerging a new and improved let's verify
step by step called qar Drawing upon
enhanced inference time compute to push
the graph toward 100% if you want more
details on that process reward model
check out the video I did back then
called double the performance but the
very short version is that they trained
a reward model to notice the individual
steps in a reasoning sequence that
reward model then got very good at
spotting erroneous steps furthermore
when that model concluded that there
were no erroneous steps as we've seen
from the graphs that was highly
indicative of a correct solution notice
also that sometimes it could pick out
such a correct solution when the
original generator gp4 only outputed
that correct solution one time in a
thousand furthermore the method somewhat
generalized out of distribution going
Beyond mathematics to boost performance
in chemistry physics and other subjects
so was it potentially the million dooll
inference run that spooked the
researchers or was it the potential to
make radical breakthroughs in science
and a further bit of supporting evidence
for this Theory comes again from the
information it gives us a rough timeline
in the months following the Breakthrough
SVA had reservations about the
technology and in July he formed the
super alignment team so the original
breakthrough whatever it was had to have
come way before July that would fit much
more with it being associated with let's
verify step by step or again maybe that
combination of process reward modeling
and inference time compute and in a
genuinely fascinating recent conference
call this is what Ilia satk said in
reply to a question asking about if
models could produce mathematic School
conjectures how original or creative are
the latest uh large language models of
course we know that for instance Alpha
go did some pretty creative moves when
it won uh its match in South Korea so
that's possible but to be very concrete
um do you think the existing models or
some uh you know the next
GPT 4 say GPT 5 or so will be able to
State a a new nontrivial mathematical
conjecture I'm not saying proving it I'm
saying stating it who who think it's
possible within the next five
years are you sure that the current
model cannot do
it I'm not sure absolutely do you know
whether I can
I mean let me give let me let me give
you an example of something creative
that gpg 4 can already do obviously we
would have all loved to hear ilas sat's
full answer to that question but we
never got a chance but here's where we
get to arguably the strongest bit of
evidence that I've got remember that
name again Lucas Kaiser cited in the
exclusive information report if you
remember he had that key role on the GPT
Z project he was a co-author in both of
the papers that I've brought up and and
he was focused on test time computation
to boost language models problem solving
abilities well as the article says even
more significantly he was one of the
co-authors of the original attention is
all you need Transformers paper and so
presumably with that much pedigree it
would take quite a lot to get him
excited so I'm now going to show you
some extracts from two YouTube videos
both of which have hardly any views
despite him being mentioned in these
exclusives about qar and Lucas Kaiser
will describe in these videos how how
significant he thinks A variation of
let's think step by step could be first
he'll give you some further background
on the Breakthrough it needs to do this
thinking inside its layers that may not
be enough time and space to do it like
tell me what you're
thinking and only then give the answer
and if you do that there is a recent
paper that says the model can basically
do any computation it can even execute
programs it's touring complete and does
this really help so so on mathematics
you can tell them model hey do this
thinking but do it like number each step
like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 as you see here and
be very precise about each step and then
you can try to verify each of these
steps of thinking separately you can
even ask the model well was step three
correct was step four correct and when
you do that like this matat data set
which is a little bit tougher math
problems than than than like the pure
arithmetic it was especially made to
show like what the models cannot do if
you if you add this thinking you can get
to like almost
80% just by just by allowing the model
to think and at least of mathematical
questions this gives like insane games
and insane is the fair word to use like
if you a Transformer has a limitation
and running Tech it runs in N squ time
for input of length n and that's it
when you allow it to produce chains of
thought it's as computationally powerful
as anything you can imagine but okay so
these two ingredients give you something
that generalizes could we make them even
more powerful and this is called chain
of power and chain of hindsight programs
of and so but but I think this is this
has turned out to be the method that
makes Transformers more powerful and
it's not just mathematics where where
you can build this thinking he even goes
as far as describing it as a major Focus
for deep learning in 2024 if you think
what you know what is coming in in the
next years I think there'll be a lot of
focus on doing this thinking thing with
deep learning with language models uh
probably with chains of thought but also
these chains of thought currently
they're just prompted but maybe you need
to do some fine tuning some Lear
learning um there there will be a lot of
work there but this is a very hard
problem to solve and and we'll start
with much simpler exercises and and
probably move forward but I I think this
is this is something that the coming
years will uh will see a lot of work and
in a sign of the significance he
attributes to this method he said it
could even be revolutionary for
multimodality I think you also need
these chains of thought that that that
like you need the give the model the
ability to think longer than than it has
layers and but but it can be combined
with multimodel so in the future the
models will have this knowledge of the
world and this generation which we call
Chain of Thought in text but but
multimodality this means just it's a
chain of frames of what's going to
happen to the world which is basically
how we sometimes think you know what
will if I if I
go what will happen to me
and I think that will indeed be so so so
it will be multimodality and this
ability to generate sequences of things
before you give an answer that that will
resemble much more um what we call
reasoning he then described how this
method will help models to generalize
from much less data Transformers are not
the end right they're they're they're
and you can do chains of thought to
extend them you can do gnns you can do
recurrent
recurrence and DEP how do you see the
next two years of deep learning yeah I
think there'll be as interesting as as
any previous two years or even more um I
I think there'll be a lot on the Chain
of Thought but but very generally
speaking so also on the agents building
libraries of knowledge possibly
multimodal where the train of thought is
basically a simulation of of the world
um so I think that will be like one big
topic and I think this will make the
models generalize much better from less
data too and that might remind you
something going back to Reuters and the
information sasa's breakthrough allowed
open AI to overcome limitations on
obtaining enough highquality data to
train new models according to The
Insider with knowledge a major obstacle
for developing Next Generation models so
according to my theory this breakthrough
is less about generating trillions and
trillions of tokens worth of synthetic
data but more about using the data
you've got much more efficiently but now
alas we must get to the bits that my
theory can't explain namely the name the
information cites two top researchers at
openai building on top of SS's method a
model called qar now I've tested every
link I could possibly find to the name
qar with my theory about let's verify
step by step and while I do have some
ideas honestly it's still an open
question and of course I like everyone
has to admit that there's a chance that
I'm entirely wrong when I put my idea to
a senior ml researcher at a top AGI lab
he thought it had real legs it was a
genuine possibility and he said one link
to the name qar could be in a generic
sense without getting too technical Q
style refers to the optimal Q function
or optimal policy another possibility is
that the Q references Q learning
generically that's a reinforcement
learning technique where an agent learns
to make optimal Decisions by exploring
its environment an agent chooses actions
see how they go and then updates their
policy basically trial and error trading
off exploration of new steps new actions
versus exploitation of actions you know
have some good reward and here's where
the analogy gets a little bit tenuous
picking the reasoning steps in let's
verify step by step could be like
choosing an action after all in the
original paper using test time compute
in this way was described as a kind of
search and in let's verify they hinted
at a step forward involving reinfor M
learning they said we do not attempt to
improve the generator the model coming
up with Solutions with reinforcement
learning we do not discuss any
supervision the generator would receive
from the reward model if trained with RL
and here's the key sentence although
fine-tuning the generator with
reinforcement learning is a natural next
step it is intentionally not the focus
of this work is that the follow-up work
that they did I mean you can kind of
think of Q learning for process
supervision as minimizing the the
cumulative probability of failure which
is the equivalent of maximizing the
probability of success and after all
maximizing a sum of rewards over
multiple steps is exactly what Q
learning aims to do if any of you though
have better guesses for the analogy and
I'm sure you do do let me know in the
comments but what about the star well
again here I am truly speculating unlike
the earlier parts of the video in which
I am much more confident this is much
more speculative and tenuous Peter Lou
of Google Deep Mind had this idea de
remember the leak talked about acing
math tests he said sounds like open AI
got some good numbers on gsmk remember
that's the set of questions made for
that original verifier paper back in
2021 he said he's speculating but
there's a star in this paper a technique
that fine-tunes a model to its own
better outputs in a nutshell it involves
fine-tuning a model on the outputs it
generated that happen to work keep going
until you generate rationals that get
the correct answer and then fine-tune on
all of those rationals and they say that
we show that star significantly improves
performance on multiple data sets
compared to a model fine-tuned to
directly predict final answers does that
remind you of let's verify and performs
comparably to fine-tuning a 30X larger
state-of-the-art language model he went
on the GSM 8K and the math benchmark
featured in let's verify are great test
beds for self-improvement because model
outputs can be evaluated for correctness
more or less automatic basically this
brings us on to another strand in what
all of this actually means for us he
said for more open-ended generation
humans often provide the feedback
however as llms have gotten more capable
an interesting emerging ability is that
they're getting better at evaluation for
other things not just math at some point
if self-evaluation or self-critique
Works reliably you get General
self-improvement Beyond math so this is
a further possibility for what might
have freaked out those researchers
generalizing Beyond math though is hard
as Andre Kathy pointed out this week so
I think a lot of people are broadly
inspired by what happened with alphago
so in alphago um this was a go playing
program developed by deepmind and
alphago actually had two major stages uh
the first release of it did in the first
stage you learn by imitating human
expert players so you take lots of games
that were played by humans uh you kind
of like just filter to the games played
by really good humans and you learn by
imitation you're getting the neural
network to just imitate really good
players and this works and this gives
you a pretty good um go playing program
but it can't surpass human it's it's
only as good as the best human that
gives you the training data so deep mine
figured out a way to actually surpass
humans and the way this was done is by
self-improvement now in the case of go
this is a simple closed sandbox
environment you have a game and you can
play lots of games in the sandbox and
you can have a very simple reward
function which is just a winning the
game so you can in query this reward
function that tells you if whatever
you've done was good or bad did you win
yes or no this is something that is
available very cheap to evaluate and
automatic and so because of that you can
play millions and millions of games and
Kind of Perfect the system just based on
the probability of winning so there's no
need to imitate you can go beyond human
and that's in fact what the system ended
up doing so here on the right we have
the ELO rating and alphago took 40 days
uh in this case uh to overcome some of
the best human players by self
Improvement so I think a lot of people
are kind of interested in what is the
equivalent of this step number two for
lar language models because today we're
only doing step one we are imitating
humans there are as I mentioned there
are human labelers writing out these
answers and we're imitating their
responses and we can have very good
human labelers but fundamentally it
would be hard to go above sort of human
response accuracy if we only train on
the humans so that's the big question
what is the step two equivalent in the
domain of open language modeling um and
the the main challenge here is that
there's a lack of reward Criterion in
the general case so because we are in a
space of language everything is a lot
more open and there's all these
different types of tasks and
fundamentally there's no like simple
reward function you can access that just
tells you if whatever you did whatever
you sampled was good or bad there's no
easy to evaluate fast Criterion or
reward function if models can get good
at generalization using reinforcement
learning with any of these techniques
IIA satva has a slight warning that he
put out earlier this year he compared
the creative results we might get to
outbursts from Bing Sydney reinforcement
learning has a much more significant
challenge it is
creative reinforcement learning is
actually
creative all the stun every single
stunning example of creativity in AI
comes from a reinforcement learning
system for example Alpha zero has
invented a whole new way of playing a
game that humans have perfected for
thousands of years it is reinforcement
learning that can come up Creative
Solutions to problems solutions which we
which we might not be able to understand
at all and so what happens if you do
reinforcement learning on long or even
medium time Horizon when your AI is
interacting with the real
world trying to achieve some kind of a
beneficial outcome let's say as judged
by us but while being very very very
creative this does not mean that this is
unsolvable but it means that it is a
problem and it means that some of the
more naive approaches will suffer from
some unexpected creativity that will
make the antics of Sydney seem very
modest so that's as far as I've gotten I
might be completely wrong let me know
what you think in the comments I think
the development is likely a big step
forward for narrow domains like
mathematics but is in no way yet a
solution for AGI the world is still a
bit too complex for this to work yet yet
anyway time to move on to something more
positive after all even samman can now
get along with Adam D'Angelo so anything
is possible I'm going to end with some
positive and amazing news about music
generation but first I want to introduce
you to the AI explained bot if you're
feeling bored you may even want to
discuss the content of this video and
qar with the AI explain bot it has
access to the transcripts of my videos
including this one I'm proud to announce
that they're sponsoring this video and
their playground is honestly amazing in
fact I reached out to them about
sponsorship it's that good their
playground is super easy to use even if
you're not from a coding background and
as they know their speech detex model
conforma 2 is state-ofthe-art and it is
particularly good on Alpha numerics a
perfect example of that is how it can
transcribe GPT 4 that is something in my
transcripts that so many models
struggled with anyway I have honestly
thought that their playground is amazing
for anyone to use for months now and yes
it's literally just clicking to upload
your audio file and then pressing
transcribe anyway thanks to assembly AI
you can now play about with the AI
explained bot after such a heavy video I
think it's only appropriate to end with
a bit of music but not any music music
generated by Google deepmind their new
Lyra model can convert your hums into an
orchestra like singing a Melody to
create a horn
[Music]
section
as always thank you so much for watching
and whatever happens have a wonderful
day